oh cool was it before it then was that
for hail at it so you can take you don't
need a sharp knife alrighty and then the
other commercial about it ladeane to
wash a very and chop much opponent it's
abortion you say Donna you Bessie look
at a psychology amo mi use llamado pop
back okay wash them but you can either
use your hands or you can use google
kellogg these potatoes are already
boiled or so but I one in some other
potatoes so you can have an idea of how
much you should cook una Casa ready ok
so here we have potatoes you see I put
some water i'm going to add a little bit
of salad salad ok doesn't need
and as much yeah the song they have been
modeling for a while I want to check in
they're ready I thank you for I quote
them and you see no it's still a little
hard so we're going to come back here in
the comments and I want each of you to
take the fourth and put his potatoes
were couple of key of course but when
you feel that there is not much
resistance then the potatoes are ready
so this is what happened with Vegas that
you're feeling right now okay good back
to work don't live in Boyle no one magic
see my just going to use couple of
pieces look good you want to remove or
the Icemark that's a really dirty and
also are right and then you're just
going you can cut them so when you have
mini it's going to be easier to chop
them oh alright okay you don't need too
much olive oil again you just need
enough to work is this penning leaf
large just enough so that the veggies do
not stick as well okay yeah yeah what it
is
come to yes and I yo okay so what is
going on here apart from the potatoes
lettuce well yes I'm retiring the water
because that's where we will knock you
when they're ready in the meantime we
are preparing the three different kinds
of sauces we're making a tomato sauce
and for that we are making is afflicted
that's a bit more rich and what we
prepared last time in the sofrito we put
tomorrow sit down okay roster Jojo I
love you yes so then we will add the
pasta penne Pomodoro a little bit of
soul tiny bit of sugar and we just let
it go measure the chair a little bit
important [ __ ] on here i'm reparing
another dog sauce very very simple so
this is gerald tramble the gorgonzola
and the few spoons of milk so while the
knock your cooking we will just melt
this free and then we look at Sonya here
with the gorgonzola
and then finally another classic which
is really really easy but is now take on
bordeaux's a shower so we will slowly
try the salvia in the full of bourbon
and a positive attitude every time we
saw sonoma Mangiamo cool de la cocina
here we have forgot that when they were
dry i waked them where were four kilos
of Aqaba so for each kilo you want to
add 70 grams of flour again I'm giving
you numbers but you will need to adjust
things get you know first step we need
to match the guy you can use the
measured you can use Forks there are
potato risers we don't have one here
right now Georgey yeah you know very
nice question yeah do you have faulty
put the potatoes oh my god happen now we
can use much measure first step on the
counter and yes some concentrations on
the counter that and then we'll do that
so 70 grams of flour per kilo there are
four kilos so good Shane release and
then we add one egg per kilo so four
eggs you want first to slightly beat yes
and then salad cuanto salad other thing
Oh available girl so this is it that's
what you want to do as a starter and
then we will make this stop we want to
be smooth and elastic you don't need to
like
me if not just put everything together
and then we will roll it and make cuts
our streams like breadsticks and then
cut them one step at a time so first
prepare
and then we need to add salt to the
water and if we were cooking pasta now
stop saying back last no more Busta okay
the personality one of their homemade
and area and then what you boys is that
what happens with holiday they rise when
they're cooked so it's really helpful
because you can you just look like pick
them off the top yes so we would just
make them all right and then we're going
to put your favorite song and finally my
jar oh my god i love i make a masala a
Yaqui with gently put them
yeah the spot is a little bit too big
for this purpose okay I want you to come
and see you see that there are some
gnocchi that are coming to the surface
oh it's really good oh and if you go
parmesan on it I really like it
you